i'm done
oops can i ask representative porter to
go off mute i need to ask you a question
i'm here sir um
it looks like we have a replacement
coming in today for
yes representative pimentel but
um there was some confusion whether he
was coming first thing in the morning or
for the afternoon
executive session okay so he should be
arriving
sometime hopefully this morning but he
didn't think he could get here by 8 30.
okay uh i just when he does arrive you
can help me
uh make sure that i notice everybody
that he's just doing
all right we're all set uh chairman
thank you christine
and it on the uh on those folders
uh it's it's hp 340 that is the early
bill that needs to
be sent in by noon and so that's the one
to be on the lookout for outside the
room by 10 o'clock
okay great i have brad coming down to
pick it up around 10.
okay and and i sent you the an email
to be able to print out the committee
report
perfect and i sent it to heather and so
we're all good
right thank you you're welcome
so you can go ahead with the script
whenever you're ready
campaign
that's right you gave me one last year
and yeah you can you could wipe off your
glasses with this bench
all right let's get started uh good
morning everybody this is the municipal
and county government committee in
congress
on this 18th day of
february 2021 as chair of the municipal
and county government committee i find
that due to
the state of emergency declared by the
governor as a result of the covert 19
pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67 of
the governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a public hearing on bills
referred to the committee
an executive session may follow
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting however
in accordance with the emergency order i
am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously
during the meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform
or by telephone as well all necessary
access information has been made
available in the house calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general
court the notice of this meeting
complies with house rules and rsa 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call 271
3600 or email hcs
leg.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
christina daya is the staff member
assisting us please note that all votes
that are taken during this meeting
shall be done by roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anybody in the room with you
during this meeting which is required
under the right to no longer
ask the clerk to call the role
here and uh i am uh actively at the uh
at the state house
president looks to you
representative
here in the committee room
representative mcbride yeah
representative melvin here hello
representative here and i'm alone
i'm at my home office in brookline and
i'm alone
in this room however there are family
members elsewhere in the house
i'm here in my home in hillsborough i'm
alone in the room but my husband is home
with me
i'm here in dover new hampshire uh on my
own
don't know where the cat is today
yeoman good morning i am in my home in
exeter
uh my husband is in the house and i have
a plumber coming at some point
but i am alone
am here in my home office in northampton
with surrounded by all my friends so i'm
alone
good morning i'm here at my home
i'm alone in my family room but my
husband is
home today thank you representative
i am at my house in peterborough new
hampshire in my
very messy workroom i'm alone
in this room but my husband is somewhere
representative yes i can hear the
proceedings
i am home in nashua new hampshire alone
but my husband and greyhounds are
mulling about
representatives
i'm here in my apartment in concord new
hampshire
and i'm alone
thank you
thank you please uh please rise and join
me in the pledge of allegiance
i pledge allegiance to the of the united
states of america
to the republic which stands one nation
under god indivisible with liberty and
justice
thank you please be seated
okay um good morning everybody we're
going to uh
we're going to take up as our first bill
this morning
a bill that's just been brought over to
us from the senate senate bill 30.
this is a bill that is actively being
worked
and we are going to hear testimony and
then we're going to immediately
exec the bill and send the paperwork
over to the
to the clerk which has to be
in process by noon today that's why
there's a rush on this particular bill
so like i said we're gonna we'll hear it
and then we'll look back
so to start with um
representative matt jury do we have uh
representative
forrester with us
to introduce the bill i'm looking i do
not
see the honorable jeannie forrester
listed in our attendees or as our
panelist
i do see the prime sponsor senator
gaida who is allowed to talk if i'm
wrong and i'm just
if there's a mis-titling here i'll
certainly uh
recognize the honorable senator
forrester but i do see
i do see senator guida who i believe is
the prime sponsor let's start with the
sponsor then
and if this forester joins will just let
me know
i will thank you
thank you mr chairman honorable members
of the committee for the record uh bob
gaida state senator district 2
27 towns including tilton but not
including northfield
i was asked by the the uh honorable
uh senator forrester who is now the town
administrator in tilton to bring this
bill forward
uh it's relatively simple and um
uh it takes the island in the
winnipesaukee river
between the two towns known as tilton
island
also known as island park and transfers
ownership of that island to the town of
tilton
this is a collaborative effort between
the two communities
uh has been endorsed and uh and by the
boards of selectmen
uh and also will be subject to a vote of
the legislative body
at this year's town meeting uh if we can
get this through the
legislative process prior to then and
for that i'm grateful for your
expediting of this bill
again it's it is a collaborative bill
agreed upon by both communities it will
be voted on
appropriately by the legislative bodies
i would be willing to take any questions
and i thank you
for your help here are there any
questions from the committee
for senator guida yes uh
representative diamante oh yes senator
uh
thank you particularly questions thank
you
um are there any inhabitants
i'm sorry i could not understand the
question are there any inhabitants
on the island as you know not that i'm
aware of
it's a it's a rather small island yeah
but i'm not certain of that i think
senator forrester would probably be able
to address that more accurately
thank you representative lasales
thank you for taking my question i'm
just wondering
why would you go to the trouble of doing
this
i think it's required by statute for the
transfer of the property
but why are you transferring the
property it's the request of the
community
the community is plural i should say
yeah
follow up i'm just wondering
why would i mean if it's an uninhabited
island uh why
would anyone want to transfer from one
town to another
i would submit that the towns have
probably got good reason for wanting to
do it collaboratively
and i would suspect that those who may
testify after me offer a good reason for
that
my job is to support the communities i
represent and that is the reason i am
bringing this bill forward
thank you uh representative gallagher
yeah um do you have a map to share with
us
showing this island um is that in
did somebody send us grand testimony or
something with that
so i can see it visually i do not have a
map but i'm sure it's readily available
on the internet as well as perhaps in
possible subsequent testimony
okay thanks jury could you uh
make me co-host
i shall yes
representative majipudi
thank you good morning thank you for
taking my question
uh does this change any responsibility
in terms of
maintenance or services
i know there's no inhabitants but is
there any maintenance required for this
island that the transfer would happen
representative i think those questions
are best addressed to the folks who are
becoming behind me into subsequent
testimony
okay thank you
any other questions from the committee
for the senator
seeing none uh we have uh
representative lang on the line
representative ed jury
we do and representative lang should be
all set
to testify thank you mr chairman thank
you committee members my name is
representative tim lang i
am the uh representative for sam burton
and tilton um
i also uh have lived in northfield and
lived in tilton and lived in san
bernardin as well
i could answer some of the questions
that were coming up uh relative to
uh the question are there any
inhabitants the answer is no it's about
a
one acre island in the middle of a river
um
that has a gazebo on it that the town of
tilton regularly holds
um music events during the summer there
are weddings that occur on that island
the only access for this island is from
the town of tilton there is no access
from the town of san bernaton
there's a bridge that goes over from
route 3
over the river and onto that island to
give access
that bridge is maintained by the town of
chilton um
but the island is coming into some
disrepair being that
um on the headwaters side of the island
the river as it runs by is
is eroding some of the islands some
repair work needs to be done to it
and then it becomes a conflict between
the two towns who owns the repair work
and splitting of the repair work
the towns worked together and came up
with a solution and that is be
considering the access
is mainly from the town of tilton and
tilton does a majority of the events on
the island
that northfield agreed to transfer
ownership into the town of tilton
however this legislative action is
required
there are no no people live on it um i i
but i think that answers all the
ambiguous questions we had that were
coming up around this
again this is a cooperative agreement
it's still subject to the voters of
tilton the northfield
on a ballot question it's why i think
it's being moved ahead really fast so we
can get it on the ballot
uh for march um and i'll happy to answer
any other questions
any questions for representative blang
we'll go on to uh
representative hill yes mr chair
i'll allow representative hill to talk
which i've just done
i also see that we do have a map that
was forwarded over by email and
hopefully i just emailed that to
everybody on the committee
so look for that in your email and
representative hill should be all set
thank you good morning mr chairman um
for the record my name is representative
greg hill
i serve the towns of northfield and one
third of the city of franklin
i guess i'm here to concur with
everything that
representative lang and senator gaida
mentioned earlier
we did have this agreement between
tilton and northfield
i recall a few years ago in town meeting
taking taking a vote and i think
subsequently we found out that the
correct
procedure is to go through the
legislature to change
town boundaries as i recall the vote was
unanimous
in northfield's town hall a few years
ago
to make this change northfield is not
claiming any kind of uh desire to hang
on to the property
um this is it it makes all the sense in
the world for
tilton to remain uh the sole owner of
this or to become the sole owner of this
um as representative lang said that uh
the the only connection to the island is
is from children
um so it it makes more sense to do this
than
than anything else and i'm also happy to
answer any questions any questions for
representative hill
yes representative matthew putin thank
you
representative for taking my question is
this the first time this has been
attempted
or is this subsequent
attempt uh thank you for your question
um as far as i know
at least in the last 40 years that i've
lived there
this is the first time it's been
attempted um
we actually were under the impression
that uh all we needed to do
was um was make a cooperative agreement
between the towns but uh i think when it
when it got to the lawyer stage and and
the actual
changing of boundaries that's when it um
escalated to the to the having a
legislative action take place um
it really is uh nothing but a um
if you would see the property you would
see that this makes
a great deal of sense it is uh it is
by all intents and purposes uh a tilton
piece of property
but no we have never attempted this
before we work very cooperatively
with tilton and a number of things we
share a fire department
we share a cooperative school district
it's a very odd relationship because um
tilton is in a different county than uh
than northfield um we cross a river
um and sometimes that river is very deep
and wide and sometimes it
barely uh exists but um
it is a it is a an interesting piece
uh for for the history books but it has
not been attempted in the past as far as
i'm concerned
thank you follow up mr chair a quick
follow-up
yes go ahead please it's between the two
counties not only it's two towns but
it's also
two different counties correct correct
okay so that would complicate a little
more
wouldn't it um thank you for your
question
um i think that's one of those for the
lawyers to figure out
um it as far as we're concerned uh
the only thing that changes is the uh is
the shape of the town
and and that boundary um i
i know coming to speak after me is
are some of the officials at least one
of the town officials from northfield
uh steffi stephanie giovannucci
i do not know if anyone from tilton is
is available to answer that call perhaps
the honorable
genie forester
thank you next question is from
representative tripp
thank you mr chair my question was
answered by a previous
okay thank you and representative trill
evan you're next
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative hill for coming today
i've been able to pull up the map and i
very much appreciate that i believe that
is um stephanie uh the town
administrator
part of the town administration who sent
that
my question regards um finances
uh you mentioned that the island needs
some repair
i'm wondering if um an admission
fee or a use fee is charged to someone
who might have a wedding in the gazebo
or have a concert in the gazebo
uh yes thank you for your question i um
that those finances uh have been
um handled uh as far as i'm aware
although uh stephanie would be able to
answer it uh
better um but as far as i'm aware there
is a charge for
weddings the the concert series that
takes place
um um i i think that is
handled a little differently um and i
believe that's done through tilton i'm
i'm not
certain of that but i'm sure i'm sure
stephanie could answer your
question much better than i thank you
very much
thank you uh seeing no other questions
i'm gonna move on to the next speaker do
we have uh
represent representative harvey bollia
on the line
we do mr chair and uh should be all set
to go
i think we need to unmute her i just
sent that request over
actually you have muted representative
lang again
oh whoops
okay
i i see representative harvey bullia
but i do not um having a little trouble
uh getting her to unmute here
i don't know mr chair if you'd like to
go over to
uh ms stephanie giovannucci
who also uh requested to speak but i
don't see her on the list i
i just don't see the representative
harvey boldia
is uh unmuting
yet can we do that is the honorable
genie forester on the line
not yet okay so let's go to uh
miss giovannucci
i just pulled her up for you
there she is
okay uh you can start my steven
i'm clicking on mu oh can you hear me
now there you go we can hear you there
we go
all right thank you everybody um
i just wanted to answer a couple of your
questions uh you asked about
the cost to rent the island what we have
in place
is that you pay to rent the island but
you get that back
if everything is cleaned up and there
are no damages
to the island or to the gazebo
um so we you know we don't keep that
money it is
it is a town park also
we don't we have the concerts
but like um representative hill stated
the axis is from the tilton side
the island in half of the bridge is
actually in the town of northfield
which means that our police force is
responsible to
to cover the island and
to make it easy for us and
to make it easy for tilton we decided
that
the island would be best if it was all
in tilton
since the axis is from the tilton side
also the deed
when the island was given to us
states that it belongs to both tilton
and northfield
and because of that deed the only way
and the in the wording in the deed the
only way for us to
do this instead of just doing a simple
deed a new deed would be to move the
boundary lines
according to our attorney because
if we kept it in the town of northfield
but still um just
gave the ownership to tilton our police
force would still be responsible
for policing the island without
access from the northfield side
it is in two different counties and i
believe our
attorney is working on moving the county
line
as well i believe he already got a
letter from
the merrimack county uh and i believe
the belknap county
that they are fine with it
and this has gone before the town
meeting
several times because we thought it was
just going to be a quick little
you know here you go here's the island
but we found that it was a little bit
more complicated than that
so we have to go obviously back to the
voters this year
and ask for a final approval
and and hash it out for hopefully a
final time
i don't know if i answered everybody's
questions
thank you are there any questions yes
representative
thank you mr t thank you miss jim
jim yeah i have a neighbor ranuti
so that i was trying to figure that one
out um
so you made a calm statement about the
rent or it's more like a deposit and if
everything is cleaned up what if
it's not cleaned up there's damage
who's responsible for fixing and who
gets that money
to which town or county gets the money
and how is the north field
police reimbursed or compensated
for providing the protection as it
exists today
um as it exists today is that tilton
gets the the deposit if there are
damages
then we keep the deposit and if it's
above
the fifty dollars that we ask for then
usually leads the charge in attempting
to get
funding from the people who rented it
our police force is not
compensated for policing the island it
is part of our parks
it is a joint park just like they would
have to do at any of our other parks
you know monitoring it um so
they're not compensated for um policing
the parks it's not a special detail it's
it's just
you know they're just there in case of
emergencies
okay thank you uh we have no other hands
raised
we were able to bring up representative
harvey bollier or
we still have a technical problem with
her
i've asked a couple of times mr chair
and
unfortunately it seems like we are
having um
we're having a disconnect with getting
unmuted okay
and we had a did we have an additional
rep during the meeting
we did uh representative uh there he is
waving his hand
pimentel am i pronouncing that correctly
thank you very much nice to meet you all
thank you for attending your you are
attending on behalf
of the minority for uh
representatives davis
my good friend representatives davis i
sat next to her all of uh the last
session so
sorry she's not here oh welcome
we're a friendly group
okay seeing uh no additional questions
uh at this point i'm gonna terminate the
public hearing on senate bill 30 and
move directly into
executive session for this particular
bill
yes i'd like to make a motion
motions that may ought to pass is there
a second
any discussion uh seeing none
uh ask the clark to take the role
yes
uh representative human human tower
representative yes
representative
representing a van you have to go out
from you
i was so proud of myself yes
yes
okay without objection uh we'll place
this on consent
um they can ask you to write the uh
meeting report yes so thank you
and that concludes the executive session
for senate bill 30. thank you all for
anticipating that you came
and thank you to the committee for
expediting this particular piece of
legislation
next we're going to take up
hp 189 just as a notice to the public we
have already uh proceeded through that
into
executive session and it was 18
vote of 18 to 0 to itla
in expedient to legislate
next is xhb 243
yes
and that makes sense we'll certainly
make our process a little
more concise we'll we'll recess the
the discussion on hb 243
so that the sponsor can
can move that into and perhaps
consolidate
other bills that are before us on
similar topic
okay next is
next is hp 262 which will convene at 10
o'clock
so we're not going to start that one
early but let me see if we can
we can fill some of that time up with
some executive work
and lessen our uh our afternoon session
mr chair i have a question
yes go ahead what are we doing with um
hb 243 i was looking for it and suddenly
we're not
dealing with it today i was looking
through my notes for it
while you talking we're putting it aside
for today
yeah we just uh
let's see yeah we're going to recess
that
that bill to give the sponsor an
opportunity to combine that bill with a
couple of other bills so that
i believe there's going to be an
amendment that's going to move
two or three bills into one bill to make
it more efficient
thank you next
is the house bill 262.
that's at 10 o'clock and so uh
i think that we're not going to take up
262 earlier
i'm going to see if we we have some time
we have 45 minutes until 10 o'clock let
me see if we can
buzz through some of some of the
executive session and some other bills
that we've planned
for today
so
yeah h let's take up hb uh let me uh
let me say that we're gonna move into
executive session at this point
while we're waiting for our next hearing
at ten o'clock let's take out
an executive session house bill 64
l which was the bill uh about renewable
energy that was introduced by
representative barron
we have uh we have a motion on
uh representative brother on house bill
from representative lasallus
or is this representative
i moved to uh otl
uh house bill 64 otp otp okay
okay there's a motion to otp house bill
or representative lasalle's is there a
second
i'd like to second that it's seconded by
representative power is a discussion
on the otp recommendation
yes representative porter you saw your
hand sneak up there
i forgot how to raise my hand yes i i'm
hoping that
people will support us in this bill it's
important um
i have constituents whose property tax
bills will be
um affected by this
error that dra
this misconception of dra um how to tax
these facilities so
it would be helpful if we can get this
solved before tax bill season comes
around another
year thank you
okay um
any oh yes representative manjuputi yes
go ahead
thank you mr chair it's difficult for me
to be quiet
so my question
is is there a cap on
what is the upper limit of
generation facility renewable generation
is it still
one megawatt or is there a limit
for this purposes
i don't know the answer to that i don't
think it's and i don't think it's
particularly relevant to the
issue that we're that we're dealing with
with this with this bill
um the renewable generating facilities
follow the law
this is just has to do with how they're
assessed
and which tax they pay true
i follow mr chair
just because there could be
larger but you know they're not
supplying to the local but they can
have a facility larger like the fritz
williams right now
has 25 megawatt but i don't know what
their
what their deal would be to
do that a
point of order from representative
piemonte
representative porter just answered that
question
are you okay with that representative
andrew poody
sure
any other questions
see none
we're in executive session for hb 64.
we have a motion uh rich
oh i'm sorry we have a motion in a
second i'm i'm sorry i lost my place
so i'd ask the clerk to call a roll on
hb 64. okay
yeah folks yes representative trump
yes representative
yes representative selma
yes representative mccry
yes melvin
yes representative here
yes representative power
yes representative
yes uh representative
yes representative gilman
yes representative majority
yes representative
yes
yes yes
representative yes
yes 19 to 0.
without objection i'll place that on the
consent calendar
seeking no objection we'll move on to uh
executive session for house bill 132.
this is the chair i'm sorry to interrupt
mr chair but i just want to let you know
that the honorable genie
forester has joined our meeting if
i know we've already taken all that
action but she is there if uh
if you do want to have her speak in the
downtime that we have between meetings
thank you i'm sorry about
miss forest we've already closed the the
hearing on
that particular bill and the bill uh
passed through executive session
at 19-0 to accept it
but thank you for appearing so back to
executive session on house bill 132
as a reminder this was the bill that
dealt with
acreage for single-family housing
and at this point um having
uh observed quite a quite a bit of
confusion and uh
and concerned about this bill uh
i'm i am considering that the this bill
might be a candidate to retain
uh for more study uh do i have a motion
on that uh i'll make that motion
is there a second to retain yes i'd like
to second that
consecrated by ms power
any discussion seeing none of uh
like to ask the clerk to call a role on
or retaining
house bill 132
yeah hp world 120k
yes yes
representative tripp yes
representative guthrie yes
representations yes
yes representative melvin yes
representative yes
uh representative power yes
yes uh trillo
yes representative
yes majority
yes
no i think we should just pass it now
no okay
and uh yes
18 to 1.
okay so that bill is retained
and
john uh if required you write the uh
the report for that why we retained it
uh no is needed for that
chairman dolan thank you mr chair
yes i have a question mr chair
thank you um so it's niggling in the
back of my head
and i'm confused i've only been a
legislator for
i don't know four terms now three terms
the difference between what we did when
we recessed a bill
and when we retained a bill i noted that
we didn't vote on the recess
it was just decided quote unquote and
now we've voted to retain a bill
which i understand means we're going to
we're going to work on it possibly along
with the sponsor so the difference
between the two please
yes the it is within the authority of
the chair to recess
a bill at any time and
it doesn't need to come up for a vote
it's just uh
really we're doing this publicly to let
those who may be
dialed in to understand what happened
and also make sure the committee knows
uh this recessing it just moves it out
to give the uh the sponsor or somebody
to
continue to work the bill and it will
come right back to us within a
within a couple of meetings where
reading will push it out
to give us time to work on it over the
summer and it will come back to us
early next year thank you so much for
the clarification i feel
smarter already for the question
representative flee uh yes uh thank you
so much uh mr chair
and i'm sure you said it and i missed it
um hb64 is that going on consent
yes
thank you so much
yes it was
okay seeing no other questions
um
okay all right i'll take
i'm gonna go to another bill on
executive session
this is hb 154 which was the
revitalization of tax incentives this is
the last time this was in the ways and
means
committee it passed 20 to zero
and uh this seems to have a lot of
a lot of bipartisan support but it still
needs to be voted on in our committee
so what 154 if you want to take uh
30 seconds to pull up your
data banks and your brain as to what we
heard
during the hearing on uh
on february 9th
at this point i'll look to
representative mcbride
make a motion motion pass mr chairman
uh well we have a motion about to pass
that hp 154
is there a second and it's seconded by
i'd like to propose an amendment okay
2 0 2 1 0 3
4 4 h
say it again 2 zero
two one zero three
four four eight that's a different build
oh i think so that may be a different
bill that's right
three three two
would you like to withdraw that motion
yes i would mr
okay so we have a motion and a second on
the floor at the otp
hb 154 as presented
uh then motioned by representative
mcbride and seconded by representative
guthrie are there any
questions or discussion on the committee
seeing that and asked the clerk to take
the role
okay um
yes yes representative
yes representative guthrie yeah
representative yes
representative melvin yes
yes representative
power yes
yes uh
yes representative
yes representative majority
yes
oh sorry yes
representative yes
representative gallagher
yes
chairman dolan if you would pardon the
interruption we have
uh we have mr paul smith
joining our meeting to provide i believe
some clarity on
the question that might have been asked
by representative tree levin and i
wonder if you might recognize
uh mr smith to talk okay just a second
i'd ask on hb 132
for representative mcbride to write the
committee report
154 mr chair not 132.
mr chair are we in the voting mode right
now
guess what we're we're uh the motion's
been made but nobody's voted yet
yes everybody has voted right yes 19-0
for 154 correct mr chair yeah 154 did i
say
so representative mcbride please write
the
the report committee report for 154
okay we'll do and uh
clerk uh smith welcome to our committee
meeting with what can
you recognize
uh thank you mr chairman um so i i
received a
question from from christina a few
minutes ago um
regarding um and and apologize i wasn't
here
uh to to hear exactly the situation um
but uh i believe that there was a
question about whether or not a bill
could be recessed for the year
uh to be taken up next year obviously
the only way that would happen
is if you all voted to retain
a piece of legislation uh for action
during the year
and then uh that would subsequently come
to the floor
uh in the second year of the session but
that is the only uh
way that you could dispose of something
additionally i do want to
address one other point uh and and this
is actually i representative piamonte
i left a message for you on your phone a
little bit ago um
there is a minority report that was
filed with a motion of retain
retain is not a motion that the house
actually votes on it is a committee
motion only
um so if if you are writing a minority
report
and even though you wish to retain
something you have to have
a dispositive motion that goes to the
floor so i need either an itl
or an otp or an otpa but retain is not a
motion that goes to the floor
okay so so um
to the house clerk the the issue that we
had that
perhaps christina was questioning is
that
we made it we recessed a bill
for a couple of meetings uh to allow the
sponsor to do some consolidation
but we did retain a bill to take up
again next year
those were the two actions that we took
i don't think there was any problem with
either of those
okay so when when you're saying you're
recessing a bill you mean that you
recess the executive session on the pub
on on that particular no we respect it
we
recess the hearing okay i i understand
that's fine as long as as long as it's
not an early bill that's due today
you're you're okay
i would note if you recess the public
hearing you do need to schedule it for a
time certain
um when you take it up again so
uh do try to do try to have uh an idea
on that so that we can get that in the
calendar
our plan is to take it up on 3-1
okay um so yeah if as long as you can
just communicate that with heather
we'll make sure we can get that in the
in the calendar for you today
great thank you thank you all have a
great day
any other questions from the committee
yes john on 154.
yes please
okay at this point i'm going to take a
recess
for 15 minutes we have some
administrative work to do to get uh
some of these bills uh moving some of
them have to be out by noon today so
we're going to do that and then we'll
reconvene at uh
at 9 50. so if you need to take a break
and
get a drink representative power
um thank you mr chair i just wanted to
ask
um we just took a vote on
house bill 154 and i don't recall
um placing that on the consent calendar
yes it is
okay and uh let me go back
because i wasn't asked but i i wanna i
want to let you know that
my house bill 30 we had on the blue
sheet nine people supporting and zero
opposed
and on let's see
we got 154 last time mr
chair support 18 opposed zero
neutral zero right and
on weight 189 uh
that one is like i said already done so
uh
any other any others that i didn't uh
can you just repeat uh sb30 please
i didn't write it down
senate bill 30 support 9 oppose zero
okay so we're in recess until 9 50.
thank you very much
so
i i know there's some confusion
we're discussing it right now
if you watch this
what does it have to be done today okay
[Music]
okay
so you were in the navy for ten years
i was only in for eight years three
months twenty days
don't keep track well chris i'm
one of the few people i know that has an
re4 reading list
says not recommended for retention
is that right yes
me and my chief didn't get along
i was in for the decade of the 70s
the enterprise that's a price
that was nuclear power you know what's
nice about that
never had to be refueled you know what's
bad about that
it's never had to be reviewed
the uh reactors
subs during my era
the last about
maybe four years yeah then they had to
be refueled
uh subs today reactors
last like 30 years yeah i think the
enterprise
had to be refueled once and it was
50 60 years
what'd you do i was an aviation
electronics technician
holistic fire control which
may be parlance
this missile
direction control center
which was a wonderful place to work
with patrols
now hold this guy
where were you based i was actually
in a a7 we are at lamar california
in the san joaquin valley
it's like not in home idaho no it's
it's uh look what we i used to say
it's uh it's
it's in nowhere but it's right in the
middle of nowhere
yeah good dad
i made two vietnam cruises nope
not a fan of phantom jets
we had uh two phantom squadrons on the
uh first group uh
287 suppliers 186 squad
how far off the coast were
but that wasn't my job it wasn't my
concern
no
i learned a long time ago if it's not my
problem
don't make it
uh my uncle
was probably in in your job
in world war ii yeah he was a b-29
instrument yeah
so he was based on
tinian saw the enola gay being
loaded with the atomic bomb yeah
1945.
no we uh what was it a second cruise
uh our
imports were usually civic day sweet
days big day civic day
you know civic day hong kong civic day
civic day
civic day singapore
and my second cruise we finally
they were gonna go to uh
vanilla well that's subway bay
right no civic bay is uh
around the other side but it's the
philippines that's philippines
so we pulled in the manila
drop the anchor and then
you know usually they take up a couple
of links to set the anchor
so they they kept pulling it up
and uh you know we're sitting there
going
something's wrong well it was uh
it's april 30th 1975
which was when the north
we're going back
oh
[Music]
and then it really ended in april of 75
when
yeah well i i i but
i made another slight tweak to it
uh specifically
and uh driving up here today i'm
thinking
[Music]
the only thing that's actually
prohibitive right now is
changing the subject 44
i was thinking that maybe
we would change make another slight
tweak to uh
change and say the uh
to say
[Applause]
mr chairman i saw your shirt last night
did you go to the academy
i uh i have a nephew who is an assistant
basketball coach for the army basketball
team yeah
[Music]
uh i haven't uh not this last year but
the year before
you know it's it's such an inspiration
i mean all the guys are just
top-notch and uh
you know they fight like hell on the
basketball court
but you know they're all on the same
side you know i think also
i'm doing that in the context i'm going
to tweak that a little bit
i don't i don't think it's it doesn't
have to be done today
we stayed at that hotel that old castle
yeah yeah with the train that would die
right it used to be five years ago
that's how the cadets
of motor transportation and the tunnel
opens up and the train comes out right
by the south
dock and that's that's a
beautiful train station does it it does
it still stop
yes we didn't actually see the station
but i heard that train so many times
because it seems to run all the time
not as much as it used to be what year
did you graduate
back in 78 back in prehistoric times
uh were you in for
i was on the active duty after
graduation for another five years
i got out of the navy after 10 years in
1979.
what day uh
it was like the end of june oh i got up
january 9th 17th all right yeah
yep the uh
see i was one of the lucky ones i won
the uh
the birthday lottery oh
did you have a number yes i did
i well we were in college and uh we had
a pool
whoever won had the littlest number
you know got the pool but i i wanted
that i had a low number but i didn't
have the lowest
you know can you rich can you
pick up the door
yeah you talk to people now about the
draft lottery and they they go what
what's the draft how are you here
doesn't they have to pay to play
the win they never got me
i always said i screwed
i
okay let's get started back up again
it was still an executive session
that's a cardboard cut out of me
thank you for uh placing that uh in
front of the camera
[Laughter]
okay so uh at this point uh
we're gonna entertain a
motion to reconsider call on uh
for that motion i make a motion to
reconsider
post bill 183 second
motion's been made in second is there
any discussion on
or request the discussion
i'm a little confused can you just go
over what we just did
yes house bill 183
has just been a motion just made to
reconsider that bill
183 why are we agreeing that was
lemonade right
mr chair i don't see your handout
marjorie porter
or representative porter yes can we
reconsider a bill
that we've already exact in committee
uh can you remind me what the vote was
on 183
when we voted on it last week
i i have 11 to 7 itl
yeah that's what i
uh
with the amendment that failed 8-10
so follow-up question mr chair
all questions right now uh why are we
reconsidering this bill uh because
they represent the community
representatives
represent that's their recent trip okay
thank you
representative yes thank you mr chair
i was just wondering if the
representative that made the
motion to reconsider um uh was from the
prevailing
side of the question
i'm sorry i said it again yeah motion
was made by representative
to reconsider doesn't the person making
the motion have to
have been in the prevailing side of the
vote
i'm just questioning if he was thinking
about is if we're on the house
floor or the hall of representatives
then that rule
uh does uh that's playing effective
definitely
okay thank you
any other questions i just want to
re-clarify is that
isn't that the same uh on committee
also whatever is the rule for the
floor is it a different for
reconsideration i haven't experienced
anything like this this is my fifth term
so i just want to make uh be
doubly sure that it's the same
or different yeah
committee to try not to take advantage
of my good nature and
raise your hand and waiting to be
recognized
until we can proceed for our main rules
uh representative uh
thank you mr chair my question is for
the reconsideration or
any rules it's a same rule
in terms of we just had that clerk
clarify
for retaining on the floor or in the
committee
isn't the same thing to reconsider
doesn't it have to be from the
prevailing side
uh to be reconsidered i just want that
clarification
one more time because i
you know i this is my fifth term and
i'm trying to understand what the rules
are for
county i mean sorry committee meetings
and the floor so what's the difference
and why on one you know at the
on the floor it has to be prevailing
side
and on the
committee it's not
another point of order
they the
however if the bill is still
in committee he decides and requests
reconsideration it doesn't follow
i i am confused but that's
i i will chairman dolan would you would
you allow me to answer
yeah okay so um either side can request
the reconsideration however
the committee does need to vote on the
reconsideration motion
if it passes uh then you go back to um
a new motion right that's my
understanding as well
mr representative do you have something
to add a question
no i just looked up i wrote the
committee report for this bill
and the final vote was 11 to 7 to itl
the bill
okay no additional questions we have a
motion on the floor to reconsider
hb 183 it asks the clerk to take the
role on that question along with just to
reconsider
whether you're in favor or not or
considered
okay we can send it at http
representative yes yes
representative melvin yes
representative here yes
representative power yes
representative no
uh representative no
representative gilbert no
representative majority no
no representative
no representative gallagher
no jim nope
yes
[Music]
zero zero nine two eight
here the motion is to pass the
amendment as presented
the questions yes
yes mr chair is that the same amendment
we got before is that a new amendment
oh that's the same amendment we voted on
last time
again thank you
oh i'm sorry we have a second on the uh
second emphasis chairman okay thank you
uh so we need to
we're going to take a vote now on uh
gatorade
on the amendment depending how that
goes
so i asked the clerk to take a role on
the amendment
okay amendment 0.92h
yes
yes representative melvin
yes representative
yes all right
no thank you i represented
government no
majority no
representative can we tell
no representative
no representative gallagher
no chairman
yes
okay at this point i looked for a motion
to otp as a mentor
mr chair yes i'll make a motion
bill 183 pass this amendment as amended
second i'll second that
second is there any discussion
take a role my hand is up mr chair
oh i'm sorry i didn't say it yes
representative porter
disappointed in this action um this is a
foolish bill
that gets nobody anywhere and the last
time
11 of us agreed that it was not worth
passing
i'm sorry that this has happened
[Music]
um i'll echo what representative porter
says
said and and throw in my just i guess
it's
confusion we we voted we voted against
an amendment last time
we have the exact same amendment there
have been no changes
um it has now passed
and i expect that this bill is now going
to pass
on a 10-9 vote i just i i'm
i'm i'm just confused and want to make
sure that
uh i express my confusion i have it
in my notes that the amendment passed
last time
you're right i'm sorry i was looking at
a different note i'm i apologize
uh representative uh
thank you mr chair i echo my
previous speakers and um i was
i'm still confused it was 11 to 7
yes the amendment passed but
otp amend as amended failed in
itl 11 to 7 and to
change the will of the committee again
so i'm just asking if this would be
something that
i need to look forward to in terms of
the bills that has to be reconsidered
representative yes
for my own sake i believe i voted
against this
bill the last time but i in the meantime
have had uh significant
time to think about it and i had
a couple of different nights had a dream
about wonderful lemonade
so i i that's the reason for my change
of vote
representative
thank you mr chairman uh is this
amended version is that what comes up on
the legislative
website because i haven't actually seen
the amendment that i know of
and if if it's not what's on the website
can somebody explain to me what the
amended version is
or possible email i can't explain it to
you
uh you all members of the committee
except you
uh received copies of the amendment i'm
sorry uh
i didn't know who was the substitute
prior to the
start but but uh i can summarize the
amendment pretty quick in this
particular case the bill talks about
lemonade stands
and the amendment just changes the word
for lemonade stand a soft drink stamp
so it doesn't it doesn't exclusively
mention lemonade it just talks about all
soft drinks
okay we have a hand up from
representative
please go ahead thank you
mr chairman um i i am not confused by
what happened
here um i am disappointed and and i do
respect
those who've had a a change of heart um
after we have voted
um it we we all do at times and and i
think on the floor
is probably where um we should change
our heart rather than
to continue to um do this in committee
so that's why i
i am um truly disappointed um
one of the notes that i had i had
written um
when we discussed this was possible of
unintended consequences and
if it ain't broke why fix it one of the
comments that was made was that
it never happened in this state and it's
been 10 years i think since it
it happened in texas so um i guess
um i i understand wanting to support the
people who brought this
forward it's um it's an admirable um
attempt and so on but i'm disappointed
at what the committee is doing today so
thank you for hearing me welcome
i can tell you that i knew this was
potentially coming so
to educate myself
i went to the house clerk and inquired
exactly what were these rules around
me in consideration so i hear about the
speed on that
and what we are doing is
reconsideration is impossibly different
with
you know all representatives there are
different rules that apply
those of you may be a little confused
i spoke directly with paul smith about
this
welcome to that similar investigation
if you'd like to get your own
expectation but
i can tell you the confidence that will
be in our
process of doing is uh acceptable
although it may be disappointing for
some of you
the process that we are using
is further out per health
representative yes thank you mr chair
um i want to echo some of my uh
fellow representatives uh just in that
um i you know i voted for
the amendment because it made sense to
change lemonade to
include all soft drinks we had a lengthy
conversation about that
but towns still have the authority to
license and regulate all of these things
that happen on sidewalks
and they can make the choice of whether
to charge for it or not
where to put them they have health
officers to look at
safety so i find that this is an
unnecessary
bill
thank you representative gilbert are
there any final questions or concerns
prior to taking the vote
say we are in the voting booth oh bombs
all right representative
opinion class thank you mr chairman
uh this is really a slippery slope bill
i mean so you all of a sudden you're not
having
permits being required for lemonade
stands
they start selling their girl scout
cookies
and then they start selling french fries
and whatever
i just think that it's you know this
should be left up to the town
what why should we as a state
mandate what is going to be done at the
local level
this is not worth our time thank you mr
chairman
hey uh see no further questions i asked
the
club to take a roll on otp as a method
okay
representative yes
yes representative
yes representative melvin
no
now representative
no representative
no representative gallagher
no
mr chair yes
there will be a minority report and it
will be the same
as the majority report that i sent thank
you
okay we have a volunteer
okay um
now back to our regular scheduled
program
we are looking through here
okay so we're going to next have our
hearing on
hp 262.
this is a new bid
right all right so uh we're going to
open up
our hearing on on the bill 262
and uh his representative that jury is
uh
on the line to introduce it
representative is on the line
and able to uh to speak welcome
representative hotel
yokela thank you
mr chairman and members of the committee
i am here today to introduce
uh hb 262 relative to
the adoption of bylaws and ordinances by
municipalities
this legislation just seeks to
have each bylawn ordinance
state the rsa section that enables
that municipality to enact the ordinance
or
law and
only new or amended bylaws would be
affected so this
does not require them to go back to the
previous ones but only new ones
and i think that this is important
for the legislature to know how their
empowering rsas are
being used at the local level so that it
will inform us to
adjust or make better laws in the future
i think that
um residents of those
municipalities oftentimes
are confused as to what um
powers are given uh and how
they are to be remedied if they don't
believe them um municipality has that
power
and uh some examples may be
the power of you know some some
municipality to
raise the smoking age or limiting speech
in a
particular area of town etc etc
and so they might question how they that
the
municipality believed that they were
empowered to do so
and help them prepare um a legal remedy
if that if they believe that that is
necessary instead of
right now they would have to go to court
to even find out where the defense
is coming from and and so that
if if they know ahead of time they might
um
be let be asking the legislature to
change it instead of going to the courts
and may reduce uh the possibility of
legislation
that is uh or the the possibility of
lawsuits that um really should be
addressed by the
uh house and senate and not by
uh our courts clogging up our courts
also municipalities should be
advised on their
law before they issued the regulation so
i don't believe that this
is going to cause additional
leg work by the municipalities and i'm
thank you for consideration of this uh
bill and
i'm happy to answer any questions thank
you questions
uh i see uh representative for you got a
question
mr chair my hand i forgot to put my hand
down before okay so
let me ask you do we have uh mr cordell
the hma online to testify
we do mr chair and he should be uh
he should be good to speak
well at least oh there he goes thank you
mr chairman um cordell johnson
representing the new hampshire municipal
association
i have uh sent a letter to the committee
expressing
the municipal association's opposition
to the bill
and um as i said in the letter
um you know it certainly is a good
practice
for a municipality to
a stat the enabling statute when it is
enacting
a bylaw or or an ordinance but
um i'm just
not everything that's a good idea should
be mandated
and we are concerned about what the
consequences would be
as i said in the letter there there's
any number of
situations that could result in the
failure to
cite the enabling statute when an
ordinance
is adopted it could be a it could be a
simple mistake
it could be an accident that occurs at
any
uh number of different steps in the
process
and if the municipality fails to cite
the enabling statute
what what is the consequence um
it seems like for the for the
requirement to make any sense there has
to be a remedy and presumably the remedy
would be that the ordinance becomes
invalid
and that would cause serious problems
um again you know select men
city councillors aldermen are not legal
experts
and they do not always
necessarily know the exact statute that
enables
what they're doing they do their best
but if they make a mistake that should
not result in the
invalidation of an entire ordinance i
mentioned
i mentioned in my letter um one thing
that happened when i was a selectman and
we were reviewing our investment policy
which the town is required to have under
rsa419
i looked at the policy and it cited rsa
i looked up rsa 209 to see what it was
and it's a statute that regulation
regulates
uh hunting of game birds
and uh prohibits the taking of homing
pigeons
uh obviously had nothing to do with
investment policy but
um arguably if this bill had been in
place
our investment policy would have been
invalid because it cited the wrong
statute
so i just think as i said certainly it's
a good practice to cite the statute
when you adopt an ordinance but
to make it a requirement will cause
serious problems
thank you and i'd be happy to answer any
questions
do you have any questions for mr cordell
or for representative we'll take it uh
folks first representative
i think representative manchapudi and
khlee were both before me and even if
they weren't i i defer
to uh i defer to either one of them
thank you mr chair um thank you for
taking my question mr cordell
um how does this
change or does this uh change the whole
um rsa in interpretation
and shifted to
local and create more confusion
uh i'm i'm not sure i entirely
understand the question
okay let me clarify okay
um this change you know relative to
adoption of
bylaws and ordinance by municipalities
so this would mean that local
municipalities
and can change
or adopt right so this
would wouldn't this create more
confusion
how many municipalities do we have 283
in the state
uh 234 to be exact
um and you're yes i i think it would
create a lot of confusion
um it wouldn't it wouldn't
affect i mean a municipality's ability
to adopt an ordinance but it would
uh it would create problems if they
as i said if they make even a minor
mistake in
uh in adopting it if they if they forget
to cite the statute or if they cite the
wrong statute
i think that creates a lot of a lot of
confusion
follow-up mr chair yes please go ahead
um
so would this create more
legal challenges for municipalities
or would it reduce the legal challenges
i think it would it would create more
legal challenges if
my town adopts an ordinance
that i don't like currently
if i want to challenge it i have to find
some reason like you know this isn't
authorized it's unconstitutional or
something like that
but under this if if the selectmen
simply forget to write
down this the uh statutory citation i
can say
aha you didn't do this the ordinance is
invalid
thank you senator trill evan
representative clee and representative
maggiore were ahead of me
so representative clee i defer to you
okay uh that's where you want to do it
thank you very much uh representative
and thank you very much uh mr chair
um i'm not quite sure who this question
should go to it probably should
um go to representative um yokela
um the the question that i have is
in in in nashua when we create signage
um we often we almost always
cite the ordinance we also
uh often will cite the rsa
if the rsa were to change
um which they often do we would have to
replace the
signage and so on um and and i would
recommend that we do that but it can be
costly if we don't do it
um on a timely manner and i
my concern is just that if we have the
wrong rsa
cited um this could leave us open to
lawsuits is is that an
exception to the rule and i and i guess
i put that to representative uh
yokela
thank you for the question um
this statute or this uh
um change in law does not
uh contemplate the change of a statute
um and so if if they
enact the rsa that enables it at a
specific point
um there is no method for going back and
saying okay now the rsa has changed
let's enact another statute or another
um ordinance or bylaw that amends it
that amendment would need to
uh state the new rsa but
i think it would be
inappropriate to say that um
the the the bylaw and ordinance would
automatically become invalid at this
at the time of the rsa change i think
that
it would be when you're citing rsas it's
possible to just
to say that it's you know
as of blah blah date and you would be
able to look up that statute and see
um where that power
is and if it gets repealed if that power
is repealed then obviously it will
um and it will
affect the ordinance or by law but if it
just moves sections
i think that it will not invalidate the
the bylaw but i think that that is um
something that could be addressed
by an amendment thank you to make it
more clear sorry
thank you thank you mr chair thank you
representative
once again i i don't mean to be rude mr
chair but representative maggiore had
his hand up before i did
so i'll defer to him that's okay i'm
calling on you next so
go ahead i'll go real quick thank you mr
chair and i believe
my question will be for cordell but i
certainly welcome the input from
representative yokela can a state
statute
have a whole harmless clause in it
um a hold harmless clause
do i need to so mike my concern cordell
is exactly yours i
i i'm the chair of my select board i
take great
pride in and pleasure in in reviewing
statutes when we're going through
something what happens if i make a
mistake
can can this statute say you know
something to your concern failure to
cite the proper statute
um shall you know you know a whole
harmless clause in case i screw up
because i actually have screwed up
before
um 12 times in the last 12 minutes
yeah i mean i i i suppose you could you
could put in a provision saying that the
failure to cite
the statute shall not uh
shall not cause the ordinance or bylaw
to be
invalid or ineffective but
uh if you do that you're saying that it
doesn't have any consequence and if it
doesn't have any consequence then what's
the purpose
what's the point of uh enacting the
requirement in the first place
thank you either you can have
something with with no consequence or
something with bad consequences
thank you thank you
uh regardless of what our people's hands
were up i'm going to go to
representative
mr chair thank you very much and i
promise not to uh
impose on your generosity i think my
question
um well once upon a time i was a
preschool teacher
and we had this great book that we used
with our kids
that helped them with fine motor
coordination and eye hand and it was
called work jobs
this bill strikes me as a make work
job bill in the sense that
those of us who are involved with making
laws
local officials enforcing laws
um legislators in our
senate and house and we know how laws
are created in our state
this strikes me as
i i can't think of the correct word
unnecessary usury to the to the users
um and and creating um creating work
where work doesn't need to be done we
know how bylaws and ordinances are
affected in towns and we know how they
can be created we don't need to add this
mandate on top of it
sorry that wasn't a question it was a
statement
i i'd be happy to tweet it as a question
and answer it
please you want to reform your statement
one more question so what do you think
cordell
i i appreciate the question and and i
i sort of agree i don't entirely agree i
mean
i as i said i do think that the the
exercise of of uh
citing the statute when you when you
enact a bylaw
or an ordinance is a good one um
if every time the town the selectmen the
aldermen whoever adopt an ordinance
they would look at each other and say
what statute allows us to do this
let's figure that out and let's write it
down i think that would be a good thing
because they do need to understand that
you can only
adopt an ordinance if it's authorized by
state law
so i do think it's a good thing to go
through that exercise but i
but i agree with you that it's a bad
thing to mandate it
because if if they fail to do it
and there's a state statute that says
you have to do
it then the failure is going to result
in someone challenging the ordinance
and that real problem
thank you next representative
thank you mr chair uh my question is for
representative yokela
and thank you for taking my question um
will this exercise involve
someone at a municipality in the
administration level
reviewing every year what rsa has
changed and does it affect
our policies and does it add to
somebody's duties
thank you for the question uh i
alluded to before if it was the will of
the committee that their concern was
that you know an rsa
change would require an amendment to a
bylaw and ordinance
i'm happy to draft an amendment that
states that
um the rsa would essentially
follow the the um the bill
the bylaw ordinance so that they
wouldn't need to
uh reenact reenact or amend it every
single time an rsa change they would
just
like state the date of the
um you know obviously the date of the
effective
date is already going to be on the bill
or the ordinance or the bylaw
so so it would only be
to say like the rsa and section
at the time of uh
enactment would be
uh required and then
future changes to the rsa would not be
relevant to the
bylaw ordinance unless the power was
completely repealed
but thank you for the question hey
representative
no i apologize i just didn't lower my
hand
representative question
uh i believe representative guthrie had
his hand up before me so
don't go ahead
i learned
anyhow uh thank you for taking my
question
uh listening to all this i
i have this
sense of wonderment and that uh
why shouldn't the town this is for mr
cordell
why shouldn't the town know what
is permitted uh
by rsas when they write new ordinance
ordinances
if you're asking why why they shouldn't
know what is permitted that
i think they should know as i said in
response to representative truleven
i think it is a very good idea for them
to ask themselves every time
what what statute enables this
uh what statute authorizes us to do this
and i i think they should i think
uh it is a good idea to cite the statute
when you
adopt an ordinance but the making the
failure to do so
result in the invalidity of the
ordinance
is just i see it as a formula for
disaster
um and i guess i make the analogy
uh does the state legislature every time
it passes a law
does it cite the provision of the new
hampshire constitution that authorizes
it to do so
and if it were required to do so and
didn't
um what kind of what kind of mess would
that create
i think it's a pretty good analogy um so
if if the state isn't going to require
that for the
state legislature i don't think it
should require it for our cities and
towns
thank you representative thank you mr
chairman
a question is i think from the sponsored
representative to royale
and it's pretty much pretty much your
question has been
asked maybe three or four times as by
other people but
i always when i look at a bill like this
i ask
what's driving it what's the reason for
it
and i'd suggest to you uh
that i ask you do you have any instances
where selectmen or town councils or city
councils
uh do are behaving in this manner i'd
suggest
from my experience that
these kind of boards making these kind
of laws
do in fact do what you're asking and i
think the question is well
taken that they should be asking the
question
whether or not they have the authority
but i'd suggest to you
that that's being done and asked
if you have any issues instances
where this is not the case uh and as
that's what's driving the bill
[Music]
thank you for the question
um in my introductory testimony i
i suggested a couple of
um instances where people might be
confused as to where
the power for the municipality uh
came from um one of those was
the raising of smoking age by a
municipality
and another is limiting uh
speech in a particular area of town and
so i think that those
are definitely something that the state
and legislatures would want to consider
as as
it's not clear from from the face of it
where those
those powers came from so thank you for
the question
i have a follow-up yes
but my question is uh do you have any
instances
of where councils are boards
or committees actually don't go through
that exercise
my experience is if you have a situation
where it's not clear that whether or not
you have the authority
that you do go into the rsas and if
that's necessary
you even go to your town council
that this implies that the board's
committees and
councils within the state of new
hampshire are not
paying attention to what the rules and
regulations are
as far as their relationship between the
state
and the town and i'll be honest with you
as a long time selectmen
uh and on many boards i actually resent
the fact that they
the implication is that uh
we do not do uh due diligence
when we make our laws and uh
uh ordinance at the local level
thank you for the follow-up um
[Music]
if you're asking which specific
ordinances
um do not list a rsa currently
i'm happy to um find
a few examples for you there's going to
be
a long list if if i tried to find all of
them
but um i definitely agree that
some uh or most
if not all of the selectmen
and uh town councils etc etc
um or city councils um
are trying to stay within the
the bounds of the law and the powers
granted to them by the legislature
um the the question is whether or not
what
they it is clear to both
the legislature and the residents of
that
that municipality
that they did so and
i believe that um just
referencing the rsa that they did look
up
and or did get advised by council that
it was enabling them to make this this
bylaw or ordinance just notating that in
the
ordinance and by law is not um
an undue burden so thank you for the
question
thank you representative gilman here's a
follow-up question
yes i did i i muted myself and didn't
get a
chance to ask you to ask you for
permission
thank you mr chair excuse me
so i'd like to follow up my previous
question with the representative
vioquela
because i feel it wasn't really answered
a town or city a municipality has a
book of
policies and and ordinances
and they reference for good practice
references
the particular rsa that um those
issues come under when you know i'm
looking at a book here of
of changes to rsas and repealing rsas
when that happens uh you know i
understand that a town may
or should a good practice review their
rsas
their policies and and etc
annually but i don't find that that
happens so my question is
whose job is it going to be to look at
all the changes in rsas
who's going to tell a municipality that
these rsas have changed and you must
review all of your
work to be sure you follow them so
i find that this makes work and i want
to know who's
who's going to pay for it who's going to
take care of it
thank you for the question i disagree
that it will create work if
the proposed amendment that i referenced
in the answer to your first question
was enacted if an rsa
changed it would not necessarily have
any effect on the bylaw or ordinance
if an amendment to this
legislation was proposed to that effect
and adopted
and so it would only um
come into play that anyone wouldn't at
the town would need to know
if the power was completely repealed and
therefore they wouldn't be able to have
such an ordinance and by law
that would be the only reason i
am suggesting that they would need to
know at the
at the town level i'm suggesting that
they that i draft an amendment
to address your concerns of additional
work at the
at the local level so thank you for the
question
are there any other questions in the
committee yes representative
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative yokela
for presenting this bill um i'm looking
for some clarification
on a particular point and my question is
if this bill becomes
law and if a municipality fails to cite
the rsa or if it's an error in citation
does this in fact legally invalidate the
ordinance
or is that the case if and only if
it is challenged in the courts and if it
does in fact
legally invalidate the um cited
ordinance could somebody provide me with
rsa
that provides for that thank you
thank you for the question i i do
believe that it would need to be first
challenged in court
and during that process obviously it
would be lengthy
uh this the um selectmen or
town or city council would be able to
enact
an amendment during that time frame and
uh reference the rsa in the meantime and
address the issue before any
action by the courts invalidated as
particular ordinance so thank you for
the question
representative i have a question for you
you saw this
bill or a very similar bill last year
was uh substantially the same content i
know that
we had some issues in the committee with
perhaps uh slowing down an unfunded
mandate given the fact that
it was thought to be some considerable
cost
associated with especially those towns
who had
that give you a visual multiple figuring
financial avoidances
uh if you were thinking in a non-digital
mode
that would have to go through but i know
we're talking about enabling and going
forward
but still the thought would be that
there would be
certainly some cost associated with
doing that research
and publishing that information
in the in the book avoidance or on the
website
how do you how do you uh tackle that
question about
slowing down and unfunded
thank you uh for the question yes i did
submit
uh uh
substantially similar bill in the pre
previous session
however it was requiring
it would have required going back and
amending all the previous
um bylaws and ordinances
and not just the ones that are
being enacted or amended and so
um i believe that the ones
the new bylaws enacted or amended are
already having this review
done and so it wouldn't
create an increased cost and it wouldn't
be um
an unfanded mandate in that sense
because they're already doing that
currently it would just be the
additional you know
one sentence or something like that on a
piece of paper
it wouldn't be any work that
wasn't already being done if i i did
agree
last time that going making uh
city councils and towns go back and
review all of the
uh bylaws and mandates previously
enacted that could be seen
as a unoffended mandate and so that is
why i
amended the uh the proposal to this bill
as you see before you today thank you
for the question
thank you any other questions from the
committee for the
sponsor or anything
seeing none thank you very much
gentlemen and we're going to
recess the hearing on 262.
okay our last business of the day and i
think
when we're done with this i think uh you
can take the afternoon
if we will have accepted all the bills
that was still open for that
purpose i'm going to look at uh
concrete9
that's the constitutional amendment
number nine
that had to do with limiting tax
increases
for people who are disabled
and seniors
representative
um i just wanted to go back to
d2 if you could kindly tell me the blue
sheet
i would appreciate it yeah
we have um in support and three opposed
thank you
representative porter mr chair
maybe i'm losing it today are we not
hearing hb 22 84
this morning uh
we are we're going to be hearing that
next now that'll be
and that hearing was at 10 30 right
now are we doing that now then or are we
doing
um an executive session on cacr4
what's the purpose of the council it
doesn't really make much difference to
me
we should do a new one if you'd like to
do 284 first that's fine
if you have any uh council have a rather
committee have a preference
is there somebody waiting to testify do
we have people waiting to testify
uh representative majority do we have
people waiting to testify at
284 we do mr cordell johnson from the
nhma
is the one person listed on our list and
he is
available
so understanding that
if you've got someone that's waiting uh
we'll take 34 first so that we don't
have them on the line
just sitting here uh
is representative mcbeath here to
introduce her bill
no however
i will be glad to introduce it if need
be
what are your comments
yes i said i'll be glad to introduce the
bill if need be
let's see on the schedule
representative if you don't have anyone
else
i do not yeah i did not see the prime
sponsor for 284
again only cordell johnson who is
available
bill 284 extends the deadline for
requests
or restoration of lots that were
involuntarily merged
lose it out two
no mr chair i was just going to
introduce the bill so that we could
we could hear it but you've it looks
like you've just done it so i guess i
don't need to
thank you
all right is there any uh any questions
uh
there's not really anyone's questions i
can't really answer uh any questions
representative porter can if anyone has
any questions
uh about this i really don't want to
entertain discussion
uh prior to uh exactly but uh
if we haven't we do have cornell johnson
cordo would you like to operate a
testimony
uh yes thank you mr chairman um and
committee members
i i did send a letter to the committee
about this
uh bill yesterday and as i said in my
letter
this is a very complicated subject
and uh if i if i were to try to
go through it here it would probably
take me um
10 minutes which i suspect you don't
want to
listen to uh and and my explanation
would probably
confuse more than clarify however i
think my letter is pretty clear
so what i'm going to do is encourage
committee members to
read the letter that i emailed yesterday
or last night maybe
we do oppose the bill
basically our position is
there has been a period during which
property owners have been able to
request their previously merged lots
to be unmerged uh that period has been
open for 10 years
uh it will expire at the end of 2021.
it's already been extended once and we
don't think that it needs to be extended
again
um so our position is that the
uh the bill should be found inexpedient
to legislate
given that uh testimony i will resist
the temptation to
accept this very short bill today
and ask many members make sure you
make yourself aware of the ancient
submitted letter
and read it and we will accept it in our
next session
on march 1st
[Music]
the testimony on this bill
seeing none i'm going to close the
hearing on
on house bill 284 as presented
again i'd like to ask you to make sure
you have several hands up i i didn't i
see one hand up
uh representative and then
representative power had her real hand
up a moment ago
okay
thank you mr uh chairman i have a
question for
mr johnston um
the uh description uh
says that this bill requests a
restoration of lots that are
involuntarily merged
i i understand people will merge lots
but it's
more on a voluntary they want to do it
because
they want to lower their taxes but could
you explain to me what an
involuntarily merged slot is
i can uh this was this was a very
long explanation that i was trying to
spare you
um and it is in my letter which i
realize you probably didn't
get because you're not a regular member
of the committee
but i'll i'll summarize it as briefly as
i can
surprises when when a town adopts
a zoning ordinance and typically it
includes
for example minimum lot sizes in the
ordinance
so if your town adopts a an ordinance
with a one-acre minimum lot
size and you have an existing
lot that's half an acre that is now a
non-conforming lot
and it can't be developed unless the
town includes what's called a
grandfather clause
in its ordinance which allows
for the development of pre-existing lots
and most towns do have a grandfather
clause
that allows for the development of
pre-existing lots
but if you have several
non-conforming lots that are adjacent
to each other many town zoning
ordinances
will treat the and their their
substandard lots
many town ordinances will treat those as
to be
automatically merged so as to
result in one lot that does conform
um rather than a bus rather than several
substandard lots
so the issue is if i have three
substandard lots that were
automatically merged when the ordinance
was adopted
there was this enactment ten years ago
that allowed me to go to the town
and essentially unmerge those lots
um and and that the restoration of those
of those merged lots
now creating several substandard lots
again creates
significant uh concerns
but when this was when this statute was
enacted back in
2011 um it gave people
at first a five-year period during which
they could go to the town and request
that their
to be restored that period was extended
for an additional five years and now
this bill requests
that it be extended for two more years
and our position is it's been extended
long enough
uh property owners have had enough time
to
to do this um
and the bill is unnecessary okay
representative yes thank you mr chair
so um my understanding is that a
municipality may
involuntarily merge lots
for the purposes of zoning assessing or
taxation
and furthermore it's my understanding
that this is um
the majority of such an action is done
for purposes of that
of taxation and billing um
to um i guess change the tax map
to make it administratively more
easy for the municipality to bill the
landowner
so my question is is this is if
this um bill were itled
how would a land owner know
that in further additionally
municipalities do not do not have to
notice
the landowner that their um
land was involuntarily merged
that's my understanding so the question
is is if this is itled
or you know and if this um
provision to request
the unmerging is done away with
how what recourse does a landowner have
at this point to have this addressed
without
expending um money to have a licensed
land surveyor take care of this do you
understand the question
i think so and what i forgot to mention
um
when i was responding to representative
pimentel is
that um before the
legislature in 2011 gave
property owners the right to
unmerge their lots the year before that
it passed a law that prohibited any
future
involuntary mergers so since 2010
no municipality has been allowed to
uh effect an involuntary merger of lots
so the problem um the problem should
be going away uh or has been going away
over the last
over the last 11 years so i i think that
that takes care of the problem going
forward and all property owners who
had their lots involuntarily merged have
had this
period of time to have it undone
yes follow-up yes follow-up
mr chair thank you so my follow-up is um
i was just curious to know
um was there any provision that
municipalities
would then notice any
landowners um that
their land had been involuntarily
emerged in light of the fact that
um since 2010 my understanding is that
no municipality can
involuntarily emerge that was a detail
that i was not aware of
so my concern is yeah my concern is is
for
people that just might not be informed
and then
therefore this um opportunity
to unmerge their land just goes away
yeah and there was a notice
uh provision in the in the
statute in um
in 2011 it it wasn't
you know individual notice to every
property owner because if
it actually be possible for a town
to to necessarily know
every property that had been
involuntarily merged
but there was a requirement and towns
did follow this
that for a five-year period beginning
in 2011 they had to post a notice
in a public place which typically was
done at the town hall or city hall
notifying people of their right to have
their
lots unmerged and they had to include
the same notice
in their annual report uh
every year through 2016. and again
i think there was pretty good compliance
with that
representative a question for you
and that is as i read this
the current law is the
restoration of involuntarily very
flawless is
on the books and so this this
bill is not challenging whether a lot
should be
either voluntary voluntarily or
involuntarily
that's currently lost as we see it the
only thing that this
this bill does is just change the date
for effectivity from 2021 to 2023
is that a correct reading of the course
uh yes that's correct this
this merely changes the uh the deadline
for people to uh
to request that their lots be unmerged
and have the legal right to have that
happen
so so uh next question is it's
it the committee for us
citizen uh wants to challenge
whether or not we should be
involuntarily bridging lines that would
be a different
uh lsr that would be created
but right um uh
since since 2010 there has been
a prohibition on any
any further involuntary merger
of lots so going forward it can't happen
good thank you any other questions yes
representative
i'm guessing that towns thank you mr
chairman i'm guessing towns want this
just to put this
uh this whole matter to bed but the
question
to to you uh cordell is uh
mr johnston do
i mean wouldn't i know that my
property was verged just by looking at
my
tax bill that i look at every year
before paying it
i would think so yes thank you
thank you are there any further
questions for mr johnson
testimony on house bill 284
okay and we will we'll take that up an
executive session or
i believe on march 1st
all right the last uh matter of the day
i want to
move into executive session on the
constitutional amendment patrick number
nine
you remember that that was the
constitutional amendment that
a quick summary was to put a tax
increase limit
of two percent on everybody in a
particular town
and one percent on on those disabled
uh and seniors if that helps uh
remind everybody of the bill we're
looking at attacker nine
look to uh representative motion
uh i make a motion uh cacr99
pass emotion made by representative
george is their assessment
second it's been seconded by
representative true there's a discussion
on the committee
yes representative fleet
thank you mr chairman i have some
concerns about
um this bill um i and i understand
that the uh the sponsor
um brought it through in good faith and
and i do understand the
the issue we have with our um
our seniors and and disabled um disabled
um
residents and so on but we do have
exemptions that we
uh we work for them and i went back and
i and i looked at all the exemptions
that that nashua has and so on and
and we have the um the elderly
we have the dis disabled we have blind
we have deaf
um education specialties and so on as
well as the veterans
doing this um for seniors
limiting them to the one percent um
beyond looking at the two percent
without a means test
means that someone literally could have
a million dollar home
million dollar income and a million
dollars assets
on top of the home and um their taxes
would be reduced
i i would think that the the person who
brought this
forward was not thinking about um that
particular situation
so that's one of my main concerns
overall i do have concerns of
of um the way that the the tax
rate is set it's set by the dra
the the city does their or the town does
their budget
and and as we all know that's the
process
then based on their need the dra will
set the rate
i i'm confused as how this will happen
um if the dra
says well your rate will go up say four
percent or
three and a half percent does the city
then have to go and redo their budget
um because it's also relative to the
assessed value of the homes and so on so
i i'm just a little confused by i know
what the intent is
i'm confused as to how this would
actually happen
with the dra and etc and
for that reason i really have to oppose
this i do understand them want
to keep our taxes down our real estate
taxes down
but as long as the um state and i know
you know this is a
moment of controversy and i i'm trying
not to be partisan or
bring up any of the uglies but the state
does downshift cost
the retirement cost has now been changed
the education cost is coming down and i
can tell you that
we're looking at 11 million downshift in
nashua
um for this year this will
kill us and then on top of it if you're
limited to two percent and one percent
i think they're going to be a lot of
municipalities that are going to fall
within this so
those are my comments and thank you for
letting me be heard
thank you uh
thank you mr chair um being
a newbie on this committee
this is creating a lot of confusion uh
in my mind when i served on the school
board
in nashua you know we rely on property
tax
revenue to fund our education
and you know taking away the
ability for the municipalities
or limiting their ability to
juggle their revenue and expenditures
um i feel like we are tying the hands of
the local you know we
on one hand we want the local control
in management and at the same time
you know it's contradicting you know i'm
sitting through these
public hearings and exacting it's
contradicting in so many ways
so but also looking at i got a lot
more phone calls and emails regarding
this
which you know my constituents also sent
it
40 opposed enforce support on the blue
sheet
and so
you know looking at just purely from the
democratic process
i feel that you know i
i agree we have to support the most
vulnerable
i am with them i you know
i understand but we also
have to keep the well-being of our
community
and i think this limits that ability
and uh that's that's it that's my
biggest concern
downshifting and tying the hands at the
same time
thank you uh
thank you mr chair i have two points to
make one is a little bit of a history
lesson
um i always hesitate to support
constitutional amendments for this
reason back in the
1880s the legislature met
from january to june one time
in a two-year session
and at that time you could buy a nice
piece of property
for a hundred dollars in that time
it was decided by the good people of new
hampshire that they should pay their
legislators
two hundred dollars for a two-year
session
um and that passed because obviously
they thought it was a good salary for
the time
for the legislators and now here we are
in
2021 being paid 200 dollars
for two year job that's pretty much
from january to june sometimes then
starting up again in august and going
through january again and then starting
all over again
is a full-time job and the
constitutional amendment
that was passed then subsequently had
unintended consequences
of making it very difficult for someone
who is a working person
trying to support a family to become a
legislator
and also have an income to support their
family
in it consequently we have a lot of
elderly people who can serve we might
have some
self-employed people who can serve but
the people
who represent that whole group of people
between the ages of 20
and 55 are very small
i think that was an unintended
consequence and it's hard to get rid of
i feel the same way about this
constitutional amendment that limits
the increase in property taxes to two
percent a year
um if it's in the constitution
we don't know what's going to happen in
10 years we don't know what the
what the economy will be
we don't know how the state will be
doing we don't know what the state's
needs are going to be we don't know what
the town's needs are going to be
and if we are tied by the constitution
it's going to be very difficult to meet
the needs possibly
and my second disagreement with this
constitutional amendment
is that towns and cities are already
able to
set a tax cap in their community if they
so choose
some of them have
it's working maybe for them or not
working for them
but i i firmly believe that this
committee should not enact
legislation that affects
every town and city and in the state
where it might not be wanted or needed
in those towns and cities it makes it
universal
everybody has to do it it's a mandate
and
um i think given all the reasons
everyone else has given about property
taxes and
you know god bless might have gone up
again this year and they've gone up 20
in the last five years on my house i
understand i'm
one of those old people who chooses
between medicine and property taxes
sometimes
but that being said this is a
bad idea in my opinion let the people in
the communities decide for themselves
don't make the mandate that they have to
do it thank you
representative
thank you mr chair uh i have to agree
that
as it is now towns are allowed to adopt
an elderly exemption but there has to be
a means test
um so that we don't get the
as representative clea i don't i don't
want to repeat everything
that she said but i agree with
everything that she said
um and if i'm understanding this bill
correctly
there the two percent cap is on the
actual
tax bill not on the rate
and what that means is your revenue is
flat
and and its potential and probably
likelihood that municipalities bond
rating is going to
go down because they can't
you we'll come back to you so in the
meantime i'll move to
representative
thank you mr chairman uh some of the
points i wanted to make have already
been made
the most egregious being the fact that
right now we have
allow towns to um
uh have exemptions but this is a mandate
and um if i can't i can't
if a town can't afford it then
they're really in trouble the other
thing i don't like about this
is that a lot of towns especially poorer
towns
uh form their budgets on what they need
for that year and
those towns budgets are more likely to
have to fluctuate
from year to year by more than two
percent
uh because of a big expense that they
have for that year
if we do this man if we
pass this uh constitutional amendment
these towns will be forced to not pay
with cash
these big expenses but they will be
forced to
bond everything in order to maintain
that below two percent margin and we're
going to put towns
further and further in debt
thank you thank you uh it looks like all
our electrons are back moving it in so
i'm going to go back to representative
gilman and literally finish their point
thank you mr chair i've made my the end
of my point
right at the left at the appropriate
time or maybe not appropriate but
time i needed thank you thank you next
is
representative uh thank you mr chair
fascinating discussion and oftentimes i
don't remember what
um bringers of bills or people offering
testimony
say to us specifically this one i do
remember and i remember very clearly
representative roy saying to us
that this was a way to start a
conversation about taxes
well i don't think this is a way to
start a conversation about taxes i think
this is a way to start a conversation
about
one slice of what we do in new hampshire
in regards to
taxes and paying for what we want
and i think a better bill would be a
bill that is a grown-up bill and talks
about an
income tax that's my favored tax
versus more property taxes because as
representative porter said in her little
history lesson
you know in the 1880s if you owned land
you were wealthy you had money
you you you could do what you wanted
if you didn't own land that wasn't the
case well now it's a flip side of that
story and it's changed over the
centuries
and we need to face up to the fact that
we need revenue to run a state
we want to have nice things we need to
stop having nice things on the backs
of property owners and we need to start
having nice things
by sharing the burden i think a
constitutional amendment needs to be
very very very very very well thought
out and careful because
once you've got it you own it for a long
time
and this is this is not a good
constitutional amendment in my opinion
thank you for listening
thank you uh we have one more comment
coming from
representative thank you mr chair
taking the question um on this uh
question on this uh bill i i think that
said before it did it and they wanted
and i think that's a good way to start
um i just don't uh
i think we'll have page on this in the
house for passes out of committee
and you know they then if it passed out
of committee
the citizens of new hampshire would
decide for this and that's
that's the basis for what i
you need to unmute yourself there jim
there we go
what i was trying to say thank you and i
apologize is that i don't mean to have
the last word but if i put my hand up as
the co-host it sends me to the front of
the line and i don't want to jump ahead
of people
um but my concern here uh i i'll i will
say i
i i agree with representative klee and
everything that she said certainly with
the downshifting and with no means
testing
but i also reflect on the fact that like
many other many of the other 234 towns
in
new hampshire my town has a capital
improvements committee
that has a 10-year plan for
our routine active maintenance and our
replacement of vehicles
of buildings of projects
as i stated in in or asked the question
of representative the sponsor
of this bill we also have collective
bargaining agreements and i have to
wonder
where if we have a two percent cap if if
a town
like mine and many others that takes
that active role in trying
to manage expenses so that we are
sensitive to
every one of our taxpayers if i'm
suddenly going to have to
say no we can't do the ambulance this
year
and we can't do the road paving this
year and i'm sorry
you know collective bargaining you know
i still think that that's going to
create a problem with collective
bargaining if i
walk into a meeting and say guys i'm
right up against a two percent cap so
uh you know you ain't getting anything
this year i i think that runs a risk of
of uh of a grievance because we wouldn't
be able to bargain in good faith
so for those reasons i i i can't support
this uh the cacr although the discussion
is fine i just can't support this bill
thank you mr chair thank you in the llp
here we have representative
tripp thank you mr chair
um i've heard
twice today comments that uh
well the lemonade stand bill uh people
saying that uh
this should be left up for the town it's
not to be governed by the state
uh i heard another comment that uh
uh tax cap should be local decision
should not be a
state mandate and then uh
i also heard a comment that uh why don't
we have an income tax
i'm i'm wondering would that be a local
uh thing too
or is this should be something that
would be a state
driven idea
i think that we have different
viewpoints
on what should be a state law and what
should be
a local
decision uh
i don't believe that uh
that uh i know that that the
what's being discussed now is isn't uh
income tax
but i suspect that should
the point never come around to wanting
to
talk about income tax it wouldn't be a
local decision
it'd be a state decision and uh
if we can't if we can't make decisions
on lemonade stands or tax caps then i'd
certainly be against
making a decision on an income tax
thank you okay are there any any further
questions
uh or comments when we uh go into voting
mode
seeing none uh that's the uh
i'm sorry we need we have a we have a
motion
and a second otp
just just as a reminder because we've
had a lot of discussion
start my caller
yes country yes
representative yes
senator mcbride
representative he's gone
all right you're still still seeing him
here
oh yes
he will come back i've asked him to
unmute
[Music]
uh i'm acting i'm a state rep so i'm at
the meeting i'm here i'm here but i'm
there i'm working
zoom is a great thing um
what they doing hold on representative
mcbride we're in a boat we're
excuse me if he was not here when we
call the question
he can't i'm sitting right here i've
been watching the whole thing
i've been watching the whole thing we
couldn't see you representative
i need to be able to see you
so the question is to you are you in
favor
or against chapter 9
uh i'm a yes mr chairman
i just had the volume off that's all
representative yes
yes representative power
yes representative
no no
mr chair i must protest i'm sorry it was
very clear
when we were given instructions in
regards to attending via zoom
that if we were not seen our faces were
not
showing when a vote was being taken or
when a vote was being called
then we could not vote and i'm sorry
representative mcbride
was not visible to us i'm glad he had
his computer on i'm sorry he had his
volume off
but i protest i suggest
that i suggest you speak with the house
clerk and get a ruling i'm very
very upset
it was very clear in our directions how
we were to be able to participate
remotely
if i was out of the room and you called
my name and i didn't hear you
my vote wouldn't count because i wasn't
there
and you couldn't see me
okay
at this point
i vote no thank you
representative uh first i
agree with representative truleven and
my voters know
representative majority no
uh
do you say gilman
hold on please
we should have gone to pimentel i think
oh sorry
do you call my name i tight in here yes
sir
your vote please uh yes i i also protest
and my vote is no thank you
my vote is no and i protest
i protest because representative mcbride
clearly did not know what we were
discussing
and my vote is no representative
i echo my colleagues comments about the
protest
he did not know he was even speaking to
another he was on another meeting
and i vote no thank you representative
governor
i vote now
yes at this point uh
when i refer to my uh colleagues out of
objection
i'm not going to count uh representative
mcbride's vote
because it's in question
in that
is there a second second
representative mighty yes
russian senator yes
representative guthrie yes
yes representative pride
yes senator melvin
yes represent power
yes representative porter
no uh representative
no
no representative
so is
at this point
as we just observed it's very important
to stay
uh when we're in the boating road state
vision so that
we can see who's voting
so please uh please stay visual
and uh because we need to see who's
voting uh and that is
appropriately uh the vote was
appropriately challenged
and uh this current during the first
week
mr chair i have a question
yes um would this be
wouldn't this be similar to if i was in
the room lob
room and left while the vote we were in
the voting mode or just
the discussion left the room i cannot
come back
until that and then would that be an
opportunity
where it would be reconsidered the vote
it's the same thing right i'm
participating virtually
so if i leave the room
and i come back
and i lost my chance to vote so will i
get the same privilege
of being reconsidered to vote my
conscience the motion is made by a
committee member and the motion
there are certain times when
reconsideration is an order in a certain
timefruit
[Music]
i don't have any there's only 29 samples
i'll memorize please uh
um let me finish this and i'll come i'll
come check with you but
there's only one chair i again
protest i believe that representative
mcbride is at work
i don't know how he has the privilege of
being at work
well we're all here so here's my second
protest of the day
nothing personal representative mcbride
yet now we're hearing your business
conversations
and i am so upset at how this has been
handled
okay so the reminder is that if you're
not recognized to speak you should be
unused
to avoid those embarrassing situations
all right so we are now at a position
to uh we've got a motion to
pay for scene in second and that's the
uh
rule
yes
yes right
yes representative
yes
howard yes
no
[Music]
now
report
mr chair yeah there will be a minority
report i'm not sure who will be writing
it
okay please whoever going to write it
have an email
okay
pretty much done with our business we
don't have any further bills to exec
this afternoon so
hopefully you know for you i see a lot
of scowls but
representative
i guess i'm just really out of it today
on my list i see
hb 67 relative to warren
articles in efficient ballot towns
school district
or village district meetings as a bill
we were going to exec
today did we already exact that bill
have i lost my mind
67 is not ready to exact uh there's we
understand there is a
there isn't a amendment
thank you mr chair and you might want to
check with with uh
mr clerk paul smith my understanding
is if it's listed as a bill that's going
to be exact at a certain time
and date if that changes it needs to be
noticed
so people who come to hear the executive
session
will know that it's not going to happen
might not be such an issue
that we have remote meetings now but
sometimes people drive long distances
to get to an executive session
just you might want to check i might be
wrong on this again
but you might want to check that
[Music]
yes uh i just wanna you know if uh we're
going to get some clarification i would
really like to get the clarification
about
voting um in the committee
from uh clerk paul smith about leaving
the room coming back
virtual or in reality i would really
like that clarification thank you
well you all should know that i
disallowed the vote
from uh representative who uh we lost
contact with visually
and then the bill was uh reconsidered
so that first vote was uh was allowed
i understand mr chair
but
how do i put it
to would that be a consideration
extended to every member because i'm new
to this committee
and um and just serving in my fifth
term and uh doing
uh two roles
i just want a clarification that's all
the committee member
is missing or is
unavailable to vote at a particular time
and they both cannot count it
that's that's the rule but if
a particular bill is reconsidered then
you start over
and then the same rules apply under the
reconsideration
and any bill in the
stillman committee can be reconsidered
by a motion from a member of the
committee
the bill has to be still in our
possession once the bill has
been transmitted the clerk of court
may not be reconsidered at the
commitment
and that's the that's the difference
between that emotion reconsider is
if it's in water or out of work
so when will when will i know that the
these bills that we exacted
has left the committee so do i have to
think about
all the bills that we exacted in the
last
three committee meetings and i still
work you know think about okay some of
them could be reconsidered
in the decision reversed based on uh
the day it was reconsidered or is there
a limit on which
there's no limited time frame if you
want to uh find out if a
bill has been forwarded to the clerk
with
contact with our clerk he's the one that
puts together the folder and sends it
forward
he can tell you whether the bill has
been forwarded
or still in the projection of the
committee
representative
i had a similar question um i was
wondering
if we how we know at what point
a bill has left our hands because i
always foolishly assumed that once we
had executable
that it had left our hands and there was
no pulling it back
but clearly i was misinformed
so i guess the answer is i can ask the
clerk
whether a bill has been received in the
clerk's office to find out
whether we have actually given over
control of it
right it's a little different this year
because the fact that
the clerks that support us
are all basically remote so
when the file folders are ready
to be uh sent they don't actually
they don't normally go right away in
previous years they were handed off to
the
committee assistant and the committee
assistant then
do a quality control check on the folder
to make sure all the different pieces of
paper are complete and then send it over
to
the deployer uh nowadays um
we're doing a lot of remote
digital documentation that has to
be printed out and populated in the
folder and the folder has to be
at some point picked up from the led and
transmitted over
to the uh this part and a cotton
and copy so that i have to go to the
assistant
since the many of the clerks are
actually virtually i believe all the
clerics are remote that
when you leave a folder in the led to be
transmitted
it's not like it was in the past just
hand it to the clark assistant and move
forward
is left
picked up and then viewed and then
and then distributed so it's a little
longer time period
and for example on chapter 9 we cannot
that's a little different and those were
still in architecture in fact most
everything is still in our projection
because in many cases we're waiting for
committee reports for both my minority
and the majority i think we've
cleared most of that up but until those
are done
we're not transmitting the file forward
that's a piece of the file that has to
be populated with
thank you
okay we're gonna take a five minute
recess and then
uh don't go away we're gonna come right
back
answer your questions i know
representative order or benji already
have questions
so please uh please bear with me
a quick five minutes
the education bill has been retained
really yeah voted 20 to nothing this
morning to retain it
13 to 20.
so representative dolan and i did mute
the room so someone will have to unmute
it
yes we are not gonna we're not gonna
blame
we're not gonna
we can't hear you mr chairman
is someone able to unmute the computer
by the tv
christina is that the that's the one
coming up executive session on
there it is okay yes that's the one okay
perfect look looks
perfect i see it yep
okay thank you all right representative
porter
uh we need to ask you and then go
forward please
mr chair i was wondering if you could
tell me if
hb 586 the governor's
executive governor's housing bill is
going
likely to be reconsidered at another
session because i have a
an interview with the press in about
15 minutes and i want to make sure that
i'm not giving
inaccurate information to the public
what i can tell you
is i've had no input from anybody on the
committee that they wish to reconsider
but that's not to say that that couldn't
happen in the future
is that an early bill mr chair yeah
that's an early bill
that's already been transmitted to the
clerk okay
so it's out of our hands now yes it is
so no reconsideration motion can be made
in this committee on that bill
that was that passed the ocp by a vote
of 15-3
yeah thank you mr chair for taking my
question or a comment today's
executive session is really
kind of put me in a very confused state
like i said this is my fifth term i've
served on criminal justice
state and federal and veterans affair
and this is my third committee that i'm
serving
and so from today's proceeds
i am really left very confused
if i attend and participate in an
executive session
like i did today and i've done in the
last three
and for whatever reason
i cannot participate in the next
committee meeting whatever my vote was
there's was considered that
that bill can be reconsidered and that
could change
so how am i representing my constituents
and i did my due diligence
and that being overturned
i feel that that is not
the intent of this democratic process
i take my responsibility of representing
my constituents
and serving this is
my prime duty
i take it and so i feel like it's being
undermined i would really like to
get a clarification
from a clerk of the house
and i understand we are in a pandemic i
appreciate
the fact that i can do it virtually
and safely so i can stay alive
to participate and do my due diligence
and service so this is
very disturbing to me if i could
kindly ask for a clarification i would
truly appreciate that
okay this kind of thing has never
happened in the last four
terms that's what i'm trying to say and
so this is
your question you can you can rely on me
if you'd like to get a clarification for
you but if
uh or you can go directly to the clerk
or to your
minority leadership uh to pursue the
question so you create
a variety of sources to get that
information
what would you like to see happen
i would defer to my minority leadership
and i think i can ask
for clarification thank you
okay so i guess that at this point uh
representative porter the
fault on your court to get clarification
unless you
unless you want me to do it on your
behalf okay
i'll do my best to answer to get
representative
questions representative porter
what has been the past practice
in this committee thanks
hey uh i i know uh representative
brown i'm sorry clerk smith uh
well enough to know that you will refer
to mason's rules
taking on our next meeting
minority leader was
had her hand up physical hand off
yes i i wanted to just ask while you're
checking things with the clerk
um this this morning we had a request
um for one of our committee members to
um address us prior to the public
session and
i think that's permissible but
i'm i'm not sure if we are all together
as a committee whether that constitutes
having a quorum
and my understanding of the right to
know law
is that if a quorum is present it
becomes a public meeting
so i'm i just don't want anyone to get
into any kind of
right to know issue if we if we are
together as a committee although not yet
open to the public
if statements can be made off the record
so to speak
i don't know so you might want to check
that
maybe maybe christina dyer knows that
answer or maybe
clark smith knows that answer i will
take that out
thank you
here we just uh just reminded that we do
have house sessions
scheduled next week 24th 25th
i'm currently looking at trying to get
our next meeting scheduled and i'll
i'll notify you as soon as i get that so
you can
um overlay that on your personal
calendar
you have enough notice to get right into
that
um we need to talk maybe you and me
about who's going to do
defenses and speeches on the floor and
that sort of thing
um so we can talk later
you need to make sure that leadership on
both sides
okay so i think we have the
luxury if you will of getting the
afternoon off
see you i look forward to seeing many of
you in person on
first
i'm sorry next next wednesday and
thursday
at the uh sports
[Music]
so thank you very much for your
attendance and
and going through the sausage making
today
and we'll uh we'll see you next time
thank you very
much mr chair did i hear that
after the next house meeting we are
going to be meeting in person
would this option be taken out
next time i'll be on the committee will
be on march
1st and i don't have any indication that
that the blended meeting will exactly
authorize but i'm an official band it
will still be joining soon
that option is still on the table right
it hasn't been pulled under the right i
mean
thank you just wanting to be safe okay
good mark